that's the angle that the line makes
with the horizontal okay so if you were
to draw in a horizontal line that angle
that it makes with that line and you can
see here that the formulas M equals the
tangent of theta so the M is the slope
okay the slope of the line is equal to
the tangent of the angle of the line
that it makes with the horizontal so if
you look at this diagram here you can
see that here's your angle theta and the
tangent of theta equals opposite over
adjacent right remember your tangent
ratio opposite over adjacent sohcahtoa
right so tangent of theta is opposite of
adjacent which is the change in Y over
the change in X which equals the slope
now if you want to solve for the angle
all you have to do is take the tangent
inverse of both sides of this equation
okay so the tangent inverse and you can
see you're gonna get theta by itself so
theta is the tangent inverse of the
slope so let's take a look at some
examples and you'll you'll see how this
works so in this first example we've got
3x plus 2y equals 6 first thing you want
to do is want to find the slope of the
line so the way we do that has we
rearranged it into the slope-intercept
form which is the y equals MX plus B
form so we're gonna get Y by itself
divide everything by 2 we get y equals a
negative 3 halves X plus 3 so what we're
interested in is this value here the
number in front of the X that's the
slope right y equals MX plus B so we
know the slope is negative 3 halves so
we have negative 3 halves equals the
tangent of theta but by taking the
tangent inverse of both sides we get
theta equals tangent inverse of negative
3 halves now let's go ahead and go to
the calculator take a look at what that
value is so we've got tangent inverse of
negative 3 halves negative 56.3 okay now
if we look at negative 56.3 let's graph
this line real quick so you can see what
this looks like so we have a y-intercept
of 6 so that's somewhere let's see 1 2 3
4 5 6 right about there has a slope of
negative 3 so that's down 3 over 1 so it
looks something like this if we draw a
horizontal line okay
they angle that negative 56 degrees that
we're getting is that angle right there
now when you find the angle of
inclination you really want it to be a
positive angle between 0 degrees and 180
degrees like that okay so the way you do
that if you get a negative angle it's
just go ahead and add 180 degrees that's
going to give you this positive angle
that it makes with the horizontal so
we're going to do that right now let's
just add 180 degrees